[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos desde
casa iniciamos en canadá donde fue
llevada a cabo una importante hazaña con
el uso de un dron transportar unos
pulmones humanos para un trasplante se
trata de un dron eléctrico no tripulado
fabricado con fibra de carbono por la
compañía united by electronics el
aparato pesa 15 a 5 kilogramos y tiene
un contenedor refrigerado para que el
órgano se conserve en óptimas
condiciones necesarias para que el
trasplante sea viable el dron voló 12
kilómetros entre dos hospitales de la
ciudad de toronto
lo que hicimos fue por primera vez
entregar unos pulmones donados para un
trasplante en un dron
en el logro fue que pudimos volar un
dron en un área altamente poblador
y es muy significativo saber algunos
pueden decir que fue una distancia muy
corta entonces para qué hacerlo pero lo
que hicimos en esa distancia corta fue
probar un punto muy importante que es
posible hacerlo de forma segura
de seif y los responsables explican que
este es un primer paso y que en el
futuro los drones podrían servir para
transportar órganos por todo el
continente los pulmones transportados
por este drone le salvaron la vida a un
hombre de 63 años que había sido
diagnosticado con fibrosis pulmonar
el exitoso vuelo requirió aprobaciones
anticipadas de las autoridades
sanitarias y aéreas y se hizo tras
numerosas pruebas y modificaciones para
evitar entre otras cosas interferencias
de radiofrecuencia en una ciudad tan
densamente poblada sin embargo en caso
de falla durante el vuelo se instaló un
paracaídas que se desplegaría de ser
necesario espacial y de cables integrado
creo que la tecnología de drones tiene
un gran potencial para convertirse en un
estándar de atención médica anmat ya
aporta en la élite de sollana
en la calidad de los órganos y reducir
los tiempos de transporte los costes de
los órganos donados normalmente se
trasladan al aeropuerto si es entre
ciudades y se transportan en automóvil a
los hospitales por lo que el uso de un
dron entre instituciones de salud es más
directo y ahorra tiempo al evitar el
tráfico pesado
dejamos este tema atrás y vamos ahora a
conocer un robot submarino que investiga
el impacto de la lava en el ecosistema
marino esto después de la erupción del
volcán cumbre vieja en la isla española
de la palma que lleva semanas expulsando
el agua que ya ha llegado hasta el mar
el aparato trabaja a más de 100 metros
por debajo de la superficie del mar y
recolecta muestras hasta el momento ha
enviado imágenes de alta definición de
crustáceos esponjas y jardines de
corales también ha mostrado como la
ceniza cubre parte del hábitat marino
todo esto le llega a un grupo de
oceanógrafos geólogos y microbiólogos
que se encuentran en una embarcación en
la que analizarán lo que ocurre pues se
estima que todavía faltan varias semanas
para que se frene la expulsión de lava
los planes de los científicos contemplan
que el robot también recolecte rocas
gases y agua para hacer un estudio más
amplio
de españa nos vamos a italia para
conocer una curiosa iniciativa se llama
tierra ex club y son cámaras que recrean
condiciones climáticas extremas por
ejemplo para entrenar a rescatistas o
realizar estudios ya sea en una nevada o
temperaturas de desierto
aquí todas las condiciones climáticas
son controladas mediante tecnología y
cualquier ambiente se puede reproducir
artificialmente
serra -ex que es un centro para
simulaciones de condiciones climáticas
extremas en estas cámaras podemos
reproducir de manera sistemática
ambientes que tienen temperaturas
extremadamente bajas desde 40 grados
celsius bajo cero a más de 60 y también
fragante fino a
60 temperaturas o se llaman términos de
actitud podemos ir hasta los 9.000
metros podemos combinar el viento en la
nieve la lluvia y todas estas
condiciones para crear ambientes
extremos en los que podemos poner
sujetos que necesitan ser analizados
doblemente a grecia
por ejemplo hacer estudios a personas
tenemos un departamento entero que
estudia fenómenos en personas y también
podemos introducir objetos estudia este
fenómeno y sube personas y pues seamos
vagamente distinto en el camera que hoy
en las cámaras han permitido estudiar
como los cambios en el grosor de la
sangre permiten transportar más oxígeno
cuando las personas están a grandes
altitudes esta tecnología ya recibió la
acreditación nacional para realizar
pruebas climáticas con organismos vivos
por ejemplo plantas para sus
responsables es clave que las personas
puedan aprender aquí el gran daño que
sufren millones de especies a causa del
calentamiento global limpio
limpia antes de eso
de altitud y con los cambios climáticos
estos parámetros cambian y podemos
reproducir eso artificialmente aquí de
manera acelerada entonces los
investigadores pueden realizar estas
pruebas aquí y ver los efectos sin tener
que salir sin ponerse en peligro y
dentro de la cantidad de tiempo que
necesito
pues no visitaste efe diré que ese día
sin chantajes fue sense meta silver
icono y habiendo siempre cuente y poker
y server y vamos a finalizar en egipto
donde ocurrió una curiosa situación
la artista robot aida de fabricación
británica que crea obras mediante
algoritmos fue detenido durante 10 días
antes de ser liberada por sospechas de
formar parte de una red de espionaje la
humanoide es uno de los artistas
invitadas por la iniciativa after hits
para la muestra que tiene como telón de
fondo las pirámides de giza e iván mlr
creador de la robot indicó que se
encontraba en buenas condiciones físicas
pese a haber pasado diez días sin
electricidad las autoridades pedían que
se desmontarán las cámaras
en los ojos y que utiliza para dibujar y
pintar pero al final no ocurrió y sus
obras participaron en la muestra así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que hay más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]